so einfach macht ihr den leckersten
nudelauflauf der welt erst mal die
nudeln gar kochen und in dem topf etwas
öl erhitzen dann kommt zwiebeln und
knoblauch dazu werden zwei minuten lang
gedünstet anschließend rinderhack
fleisch dazugeben und drei minuten lang
krümelig braten das ganze dann schön
würzen die schreibt euch alles ganz
genau in die kommentare damit ihr das
auch nachkochen können und zu guter
letzt kommen dann passierte tomaten und
sahne dazu ich nehme gerne die
fettreduzierten variante aber das ist
auch ganz euch überlassen ich gebe die
nudeln direkt mit dazu und eigentlich
könnte es jetzt schon essen aber ich
finde käser macht immer alles besser
daher kommt noch richtig rüber zur l
oben drauf und das ganze wird dann im
backofen für 15 minuten bei 200 grad
überbacken